ausnahmezustand in l e während drinnen
die ärzte rund um die uhr um das leben
von menschen ringen bringen krankenwagen
im minutentakt neue cupid patienten die
notaufnahmen sind kurz vor dem kollaps
krankenschwester er in macintosh hat
ihre zwölf stunden schichten der
notaufnahme gerade hinter sich
ihr mann brian holt sie ab wie war dein
tag wie immer furchtbar ich bin so müde
corona dominiert er ins leben seit
monaten nach feierabend versucht sie im
auto den tag zu verarbeiten
ich sehe es immer wieder vor mir
sein gesichtsausdruck als ich zu ihm ins
zimmer kam dachte er darf nach hause
sein gesicht hätte sich auf darf ich
jetzt nach hause
ich sagte der schwester sie soll einfach
ein formular ausfüllen denn am liebsten
würde ich ihn in den arm nehmen und nach
hause fahren damit der zu hause sterben
kann und nicht im krankenhaus
der tod ist ein ständiger begleiter für
erin und ihre kollegen in diesen tagen
jedes schicksal jede trauer jeder tod
bringt sich ins gedächtnis
es ist arbeiten am rande des
zusammenbruchs
es ist das schlimmste was ich je erlebt
habe in den letzten zehn monaten habe
ich mehr tote gesehen als in den acht
jahren als krankenschwester zuvor und
ich bin notfall krankenschwester ich
kümmere mich um alle intensiv fälle
sie hat albträume sie hat probleme mit
dem schlafen wenn sie nicht zur arbeit
kann fühlt sie sich schuldig sie ist
nicht wirklich da und sie physisch
anwesend ist sie muss hier mit einem
enormen trauma fertig werden früher hat
sie mir alle paar monate mal fanden
patienten erzählt er gestorben ist
jetzt sind es mehrere patienten jeden
tag und nach allem was ich von mir höre
ist es kein schöner tod
die menschen leiden
neben dem gesundheitsnotstand ist auch
wirtschaftlich ins herz getroffen
hollywood zentrum der filmindustrie hier
werden milliarden umgesetzt
doch zurzeit steht alles still wegen der
hohen infektionszahlen haben viele
studios ihre arbeit unterbrochen
wir sind bei schauspielerin logik rand
sie lebt von nebenrollen
heute hat sie ein online casting für
projekte nach der pandemie
es werden immer noch neue shows
entwickelt es gibt immer noch castings
meine castings hier lass mich nachdenken
ich glaube ich hatte kein persönliches
casting mehr seit zehn monaten
aber ich kann mich glücklich schätzen
weil ich auch schreiben deswegen kann
ich viel von meiner arbeit auch am
computer machen
robben nimmt zurzeit jeden job an
schreibt bewirbt sich um rollen gibt
sogar online yogakurse und kümmert sich
um ihre tochter sabine in der
nachbarschaft stehen immer mehr
appartements leer immer mehr menschen
sind arbeitslos ziehen weg für robin ist
klar wer die schuld trägt
der präsident glaubt nicht an die
wissenschaft und sein ego erlaubt es ihm
nicht menschen zu beschützen so viele
leute schauen ihn an und verhalten sich
dann genau wie er das heißt wenn er
keine maske trägt und sagt ich habe zwar
ohne aber mir geht es gut macht euch
keine sorgen dann glauben ihm die leute
auch kranken schwester yolanda tommy
nacke ist wütend auf trump er trage eine
mitschuld
die lügen kam von ganz oben unsere
führung hat alle warnungen ignoriert
sie dachten das geht schon alles wieder
weg im sommer ist alles überstanden
wir haben gesehen was passiert ist es
wurde immer schlimmer und schlimmer am
hinterausgang des till krankenhauses
steht ein extra kühllaster für die
vielen toten
über 200 sind es derzeit in l e jeden
tag seit wochen die notaufnahme auch
hier komplett überfüllt weil unsere
krankenhäuser so voll sind und wir immer
mehr corona patienten bekommen stauen
sich die krankenwagen an manchen tagen
müssen die patienten bis zu acht stunden
im krankenwagen warten bis sie in die
notaufnahme können haben sie quasi die
triage eingeführt hoffnungslose fälle so
die offizielle ansage sollen gar nicht
mehr in die notaufnahme gebracht werden
ist das am dichtesten besiedelte county
in den usa zehn millionen menschen leben
hier ein idealer nährboden für das virus
das hat auch familie gollnick gomez
erfahren müssen
vor zehn tagen starb ashley veronikas
tochter kurz nach der entbindung ihres
kindes an corona ich bin am boden
zerstört
mein herz wurde mir heraus gerissen
ich kann es einfach nicht glauben ich
bin so geschockt ich habe meine tochter
verloren ich denke mir es kann nicht sie
getroffen haben weil sie so eine starke
person war ashley gornik gomez wurde 30
jahre alt vor corinna war sie gesund
arbeitete in einer pflegeeinrichtung
doch ende des jahres kommt sie
hochschwanger ins krankenhaus die
diagnose krone ihr kind corrie wurde per
not kaiserschnitt auf die welt gebracht
doch er schaffte es nicht
[Musik]
mir fehlen die worte um zu beschreiben
wie weh es tut
vor allem für die kinder alles was sie
jetzt noch haben sind erinnerung vor
allem die klein
sie verstehen noch gar nicht richtig
durch ihre meter verloren haben und
veronika wollen stark bleiben stark für
die sechs kinder die ihre mutter
verloren haben und sie wollen dafür
kämpfen dass das virus nicht
unterschätzt und irgendwann besiegt wird
weiter kämpfen das will auch er in vor
ihr liegt die nächste zwölf stunden
schicht aufgeben kommt nicht infrage
weiterkämpfen es ist das motto dieser
stadt in diesen tagen denn die härtesten
wochen stehen wohl erst noch